non ma manor bonjour merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france alors on
vient d'avoir en direct la fille de
cédric fougueuse sofia jovial parle de
colère de déception elle s'interroge est
ce que vous comprenez aujourd'hui le
sentiment de la famille ne sait trop
bien
absolument parce que passer à la
polémique et la tempête médiatique
la famille est livrée à elle même dans
la solitude la plus totale et les
promesses comme elle le dit elle-même
des politiques reste des paroles mais
les actes ne suivent pas plus récemment
dans l'actualité vous avez une affaire
tout à fait similaire qui est celle de
michel est clair le président de la
république lui-même est sorti justement
de ce symbole puisqu'il a outrepassé
justement le ministre de l'intérieur
pour dire qu'il était horrifié qu'il
avait ou de ce qui s'était passé
n'empêche que tout le monde est témoin
du fait que la préfecture de police à
financer les frais de justice
des policiers mis en cause ils ont été
libérés et ils ont pu fêter noël en
famille ou que simuler les paroles
s'envolent mais les actes de et la
réalité nous rattrape assez rapidement
donc je suis totalement solidaire de la
famille souviens d'un combat qu'elle
mène et elle a tout à fait raison de
s'obstiner pour obtenir justice
mais c'est quand même ce qui devrait
être une évidence et puis des droits de
l'homme et quand même semaine 3 alors
cette marche blanche pour redemander la
suspension des policiers a mis en cause
dans cette affaire
est ce que vous comprenez qu'il n'y ait
pas été suspendu
alors si vous voulez vous parler assez
un policier suspendu c'est à dire que
savait que alexandre langlois et moi
même
sam premières loges pour ce qui est de
la critique de la politique de sécurité
du gouvernement actuel et des conseils
de discipline les convocations à l'igpn
les mesures comment dire conservatoire
pour nous elles n'attendent pas avec son
emploi est lui-même convoqué en conseil
de discipline 20 janvier prochain
moi je suis en attente de ma sanction
disciplinaire
et effectivement nous n'avons tué
personne n'avons pas de sang sur les
mains nous avons simplement exercer
notre liberté pour celle que nous
confère notre rôle de tennis syndicaux
et ça coûte assez cher donc
effectivement moi je les jeux je
m'insurge contre cet état de fait ou
finalement les policiers qui s'expriment
sur internet y compris de façon
extrêmement vulgaire assouté les uns et
les autres eux jouissent de la liberté
d'expression quand on critique le
gouvernement ces conseils de discipline
suspension révocation pour certains et
cetera et cetera
et quand on tue parce que là il s'agit
bien d'une personne qui m'a tuer il est
en très bonne santé avant contrôle il en
est ressorti les pieds devant
là par contre il n'y a pas de mesure de
suspension pour michel est clair
l'administration a été obligé de se
conformer à une décision de justice sans
quoi on imagine bien que encore une fois
le ministre aurait été particulièrement
clément avec eux comme il l'a été avec
tous les policiers raciste et violent
qui prospérait et sévit depuis deux ans
nous écoutez moi je crois que l'étoile
état de droit aujourd'hui est un
lointain souvenir en france et je pense
que nous avons de toute notre place en
fait
j'irai au banc justement de l'humanité
ont largement nous prévaloir d'être
aussi violent que les polices d'afrique
du moyen-orient de certains pays d'asie
du maghreb des autres c'est peut-être
que la liberté en france et c'est bien
le thème de cette loi sécurité globale
est un lointain souvenir
voilà tant qu'on se cacher quand on a
peur des caméras quand on a peur de la
transparence c'est qu'on a des choses à
se coucher
alors la technique de la clé
d'étranglement du placage ventrale ans a
été mis en cause dans la mort ne céderai
que s'ouvre d'ailleurs pourquoi cette
technique son talent toujours en vigueur
en france
parce que le ministère de l'intérieur et
la majorité présidentielle le deuil
c'est à dire que le député françois
ruffin a présenté après avoir reçu la
famille chouïa après nous avoir reçus
autres délégués dj et un des policiers
suivis d'autres sensibilités dont il
nous a reçus il à propos d'un texte de
loi visant à interdire le placage mantra
les clés des tremblements et ce texte a
été rejeté par la majorité
présidentielle et la majorité république
en marge d'une possible et si ces
techniques existent toujours aujourd'hui
elles sont utilisées par les policiers
c'est pascal jean parce que les
policiers ont été autorisés par la
majorité actuelle il n'y a pas d'autre
explication
alors il ya une des vidéos en dans la
sphère cédric fau via des vidéos de la
policière des venues de cédric joue via
lui-même est ce que ça ne rappelle pas
les problèmes que posent l'article 24 de
la loi sécurité globale absolument
absolument c'est possible et c'est pas
l'idée c'est que si vous êtes malade
souffrait de fièvre le fait de casser le
thermomètre ne résout pas le problème de
fond c'est vrai qu'il vous empêchera
éventuellement de le voir le problème
aujourd'hui c'est la radicalisation
d'une partie des effectifs de la police
nationale
c'est le racisme ambiant au sein de
cette institution
la violence exercée contre nos
concitoyens et double fait finalement de
casser le thermomètre d'interdire aux
j'avoue riverains aux manifestants et
autres de filmer la police en action va
entraver justement l'action de la
justice parce que même si ça n'a pas
donné beaucoup de résultats ces deux
dernières années il a pu être mis en
évidence grâce à ses caméras de fortune
près aux smartphones et autres outils et
gadgets technologiques que la police
pouvait parfois outrepassé son rôle
d'ailleurs sauf s il dit elle même elle
n'a plus confiance aujourd'hui dans la
police puisque sans les caméras et sans
le téléphone de cédric sylvia on aurait
aujourd'hui diligenté une procédure
mensongères qui visaient à discréditer
la personnalité et son père
cette procédure aurait abouti qu tout
comme dans la sphère est clair donc on
se rend bien compte aujourd'hui que la
police est susceptible de mentir et
d'ailleurs dans le prolongement de ces
affaires l'afer qui a permis à alexandre
langlois et moi même soyons écarté même
momentanément des rangs de la police
sont des affaires totalement mensongères
qui ont été obtenues à partir de faux
témoignages
aujourd'hui la police nationale n'est
plus une bande rivale dans cette jungle
finalement que la rue française
aujourd'hui qui défend ses propres
intérêts o maîtrise de la sécurité et de
la justice
alors il ya une autre affaire très
médiatisée impliquant des policiers en
2020 on a l'impression que cette année a
été particulière comment on explique
tous ces événements
et c'est malheureusement le naufrage
politique de ce qui devait être une
révolution politique c'est à dire que
moi je me souviens avoir voté en 2017 ou
le dégagisme pour le renouveau justement
de la classe politique et
rétrospectivement ça valait bien le coup
de 2009 où les républicains se disent
très vite si marine le pen au regard de
la politique qui est menée aujourd'hui
je suis très ironique transition ce
propos c'est à dire que aujourd'hui
c'est un naufrage politique où le
gouvernement
finalement faites appliquer ces mesures
avec la force publique de façon abusive
parce que les policiers au départ sma
pour d'autres choses
ils sont là pour faire appliquer la
morale la justice le droit et défendre
la veuve et l'orphelin et non pas pour
servir de milices au profit d'un organe
politique doute
simuler ce qui s'est passé dans la
sphère cédric joue via qui était un
honnête livre travailleurs qui
finalement effectuer une livraison pour
nourrir sa famille c'est dans la
continuité ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
en france c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui la
cible de la police des services de
répression et du gouvernement c'est le
français moyen qui va au travail la
politique actuelle la politique
sanitaire le démontre très très bien les
restaurateurs sont dans la rue les
représentants du monde du spectacle de
la nuit dans la rue
d'ailleurs l'actualité de ces deux
derniers jours nous parle de quoi ne
parle pas de tilleur elle ne parle pas
de proxénètes elle ne parle pas de
délinquants violents
elle nous parle de jeunes fêtards ont
rassemblé en bretagne d'une brouillé la
six nouveaux lits du gouvernement ce
sont des jeunes qui font la fête ce sont
des commerçants qui fermerait un petit
peu trop tard ce sont des automobilistes
qui se déplace dans la rue voyez ce sont
pas des contrevenants au centre de la
scène entend par délinquance au sens
habituel du terme donc le
vie vraiment dans un système de valeurs
inversées c'est à n'y plus rien
comprendre et la fesci mian est
malheureusement symptomatique de ce
climat qui gangrène le moral des
français depuis deux ans anwar merci
d'avoir répondu à nos questions nous
parler nous paraît d'alexandre langois
qu'on a reçu récemment sur notre antenne
merci à vous d'avoir répondu à nos
questions rappelle que vous êtes délégué
du syndicat de police 8 j merci